we're now going to talk about hinduism
which is one of the largest religions on
earth practiced by over a billion people
and it's interesting for several reasons
first it is considered to be one of the
oldest religions that is still practiced
some historians would place the origins
of hinduism at 5 000 years into the past
it has elements that may have been
practiced in the indus valley
civilization you also have significant
elements that come from the vedic period
in fact the vedas for which the vedic
period is named really form the root of
hinduism as it is practiced today it is
believed that the vedas come from an
indo-aryan people that many historians
believe came from central asia and were
related to many of the people who
colonized europe now the other thing
that is fascinating about hinduism and i
really just referred to some of it it is
a combination of many cultures that
really merged over thousands of years
and they merged around the indian
subcontinent as you will see there are
many traditions many cultures many
different ways that one can and many
different ways that people do practice
hinduism but there are also four beliefs
that we want to get to the heart of in
this video and we'll discuss more in
future videos now what's also
interesting is where the name hinduism
or hindu comes from a hindu being
someone who practices hinduism
the name for what we now call the indus
river in sanskrit was sindhu and sindh
is still a region in the indian
subcontinent the version that the
persian said was hindus and this got
converted to indus in latin so really
hinduism is the term for the cultural
and religious practices of people beyond
the indus river the word india really
comes from this same root indus is where
india comes from but indus comes from
hindus which comes from sindhu and these
are all related to the word hindu and
you can see that very clearly in the
persian version now as i mentioned
there's many different practices in
hinduism many different traditions many
different rituals in hinduism but i'm
going to try to focus in on what could
be considered the spiritual core and a
lot of this comes out of the vedas
they're a collection of hymns rituals
but also philosophy and the subset of
the vedas that are very concerned with
the spiritual and the philosophical are
known as the upanishads which means
sitting down or coming near to some
people say coming near to god some
people say coming near to
the actual reality or coming near to a
teacher as in sitting down to get a
lesson or to have a dialogue now the
central idea in hinduism is the idea of
brahman and brahman should not be
confused with the god brahma
brahma is sometimes you could view as a
aspect of brahman but brahman is viewed
as
the true reality of things it is
shapeless genderless bodyless it cannot
be described it can only be experienced
now according to hindu belief we are all
part of brahman
and what we perceive as our
individuality is really you can consider
to be a quasi illusion so this might be
one individual right over here and then
we might have another individual
right over here
and this separateness the illusion of
the reality that we see around us
this is referred to as maya
and maya is not just the illusion or the
quasi illusion created by our senses it
is even notions like our ego our
identity and within that context that
inner self the thing that is even within
our that is even deeper than our sense
of identity this is referred to as
atman
and as you can see the way it's been
diagrammed here the way we've drawn it
out atman is essentially the same thing
as brahman and oftentimes you will you
will see it referred to as
brahman they're really the same thing
but it's really a it's an illusion that
there is this separateness of our
reality now according to hindu belief
in each life
you have this core part of yourself
which is atman which is part of brahman
and when you die
it doesn't disappear but it will take on
or it will subjugate itself to another
reality
so after death this individual or this
perceived
individual might take on another
identity in another reality you would
they would perceive it as a another life
and this notion of one life after
another one reality after another is
sometimes referred to as trans migration
of the soul sometimes referred to as
reincarnation or this notion of samsara
which is this endless cycle of birth and
rebirth that really comes from this
notion of same flowing this thing this
pattern that goes on and on and on and
according to hindu belief
what that next life is what that next
reality is is based on your actions in
this life
karma literally is referring to actions
but it's really
actions driving consequences not only in
this reality but in the next reality now
there's another notion of dharma
dharma is based on what is the role you
should play
given the reality given the life that
you are in so in a very simplified way
you could say well dharma is the
rightful role the rightful actions your
duty depending on your role depending on
your reality karma is how that action
translates into consequences which is
going to drive what happens in this
endless cycle now a core idea of
hinduism is to try to escape from this
cycle to awaken to the true reality
awaken from this quasi reality and this
is really one of the central ideas of
the upanishads that eventually if you
can awaken
so let's say that this is an awakening
this entity this atman this self right
over here this perceived individual has
now awoken and can see through pierces
the veil of that maya now they have
rejoined brahman and they've recognized
that atman and brahman are the same and
this freeing from samsara from this
birth death cycle this is referred to as
moksha
now to make this idea a little bit
clearer let's look at some quotes from
the actual upanishads
so this is two versions from the isha
upanishad and the reason why i like to
show it is because it shows that if
you're translating from sanskrit into
english or really from any one language
into another there's going to be some
room for interpretation but we can see
it here so this is from the isha
upanishad with this which is considered
one of the most important ones it's a
subset it's a section of the yajurveda
one of the four early vedas and they
write and this is an english translation
the wise man beholds all beings in the
self or the atman and the self and all
beings for that reason he does not hate
anyone to the seer all things have
verily become the self what delusion
what sorrow can there be for him who
beholds that oneness this is another
version of the same
verses from the isha upanishad
he who sees all beings in the self and
the self and all beings he never turns
away from it the self for he who
perceives all beings as the self how can
there be delusion or grief when he sees
this oneness everywhere so i might be
getting into an argument with someone
but deep down if i recognize that both
myself and that individual that we are
part of this same brahman that he is me
and i am it or i am he
well then that anger seems a little bit
misguided
now to get a little bit more context on
this notion of oneness here is another
verse from the chandogya upanishad which
is also considered one of the
significant upanishads and it's part of
the samaveda
as the rivers flowing east and west
merge in the sea and become one with it
forgetting they were separate rivers so
do all creatures lose their separateness
when they merge at last into pure being
into brahman
there is nothing that does not come from
him and the use of the word him is
really an anthropomorphism
of this notion that has really no gender
or
body or form of everything he is the
inmost self he is the truth he is the
self supreme you are that
shivet
you are that and this last verse is
referring it's in this chandogya
upanishad it's a conversation between
the teacher and his son and the son is
shavita
ketu my apologies for pronunciation so
once he's saying that these rivers is an
analogy for you and i and we might see
ourselves as different but at some point
we will flow and become one with the
ocean and he's pointing out to his son
you are not different from that you
yourself your atman it is brahman it is
one and the same